B's Gate 3 is being sensored in Japan or
at least when it releases in Japan spike
chunsoft is the name of the Japanese
company releasing the game in Japan and
they announc that they are cutting
explicit sexual content from the game in
order to actually be allowed to release
in Japan there are certain banned
Expressions that prevent the current
version of the game from being in
compliance with the C's code of ethics
the C is the Computer Entertainment
rating organization and it prevents
Japanese players from seeing genitals in
menus plus no displays of nudity and no
sex scene for reference balers Gate 3
has an option to toggle nudity on or off
but basically in Japan you just be stuck
on the off position they have also
removed the option in act one where you
can torture an NPC in the goblin Camp I
feel like a lot of people maybe don't
know about this but there are quite a
lot of games that get sented in Japan
including cyberp Punk The Last of Us the
witch at 3 and a whole lot more and I
feel like it kind of does negatively
impact the experience of balers Gate 3